okay so inside of the
iido Marshall
applications there's there's a catch
okay um and what I mean by that is
they're going to press they're going to
have some a spinal displacement for
example you want to catch the
center um as opposed to you seeking
control of of the center so the latter
would be for example let's say we're
fighting right and and I come here and
catch a center like that that's not iido
that's not
practical um you do see that a lot in
taiichi that tries to be Marshal to me
this is not
understanding uh the application field
and mistaking it for the cultivation
field can you can you seiz a person
Center uh yeah you can that doesn't mean
that you should uh in a fight okay in in
that I seek out his Center that's not
what happens okay he is going to uh
spinally displace and I want to be able
to catch his Center and from that catch
that's where you now have seized control
of them okay um and this is quite
different again what you see in the
Marshall in the taii people that mistake
cultivation fields for application
Fields but it's also quite different
from what you see in Federation iido
where they where they do the leading
kind of stuff see that that that not
catching there okay um so if we
start
in um at touch I I want to seize his
Center however I am not just getting out
of the
way and nor am I holding it here and
then and uh now seizing it okay that's
not what's happening so I have to yield
it and all that happens inside the grip
okay there's a catch
here so we've been doing drills where we
don't B grip this time I'm using the
grip to train me on this catch so I stay
inside the
grip you can see the projection is there
but I'm just feeling for his
Center okay catch you so the next drill
will give it some form because we have
to struggle with form so this time I
have to catch and I have to use the
forward
angles and that that's all I can use
okay
try okay
try I think I did one of these last time
this one
[Music]
isi the back foot
clears back foot clear well that's going
to be
AET
back
backp backp
okay let's
[Music]
try I don't care what you do after the
10 cons you want to come back again
[Music]
this one is slide
deviation I might I not move my feet
okay but I'm not here trying to do
everything internal there's slight
deviations of my body you feel that
right so here I am right and you're
going to watch that my hands are
yielding and my body yield it just
enough
[Music]
so to hear me like those W there's
nothing there my body is there but he's
going around it it's the feeling that
you have okay all right try